la bombe
celui-là va pas ressembler à des débris
et des beats sur mon premier sujet tu
réalises que c'est un peu seul c'est
juste un tas de lait bouilli de tuer
mais de violence dans le néant
zik était le même de ma soeur il était
le mec faut toujours branlée avant
d'aller baiser une meuf je me suis mené
avant de venir tutoie toujours après je
sais jamais où je vais finir la soirée
il m'a donné le sentiment dans
l'écriture impute un coup gagnant mais
qui va avaler ça à temps il ya quoi la
myrtille bière sirops contre la toux et
xanax complet [ __ ] bravo tu croises le
cheveu de racailles tu te doutes
une seconde qu'il va finir par se
pointer devant chez toi dans sa caisse
tous les jours jusqu'à la fin de ta
fille tu es au lycée
tu devrais te faire des amis de ton âge
moi j'adore la neige ce week-end chez
paul c'est trop mortel tu te voilà les
vendre ma boîte à fait
attends tu crois que je vais me pointer
avec ton bateau c'est qu'ils vont 12 ou
loire vont acheter dit que je suis
dingue aussi
tu fais vraiment con en ce moment c'est
tu me fais là s'est en tout cas c'est
nick g saison ouais je sais quoi
[Musique]
les gamins font des erreurs c'est
justement l'intérêt dans les trains
[Musique]
et je crois que l'heure est venue pour
toi c'est un tatouage permanente pas
tatoué tongs daddy sur ton torse et ça
je peux savoir ce que ça veut dire mais
non